hallo mein name ist herzlich willkommen
hier heute zu einem neuen video viele
hatten gesagt luca du hast ja jetzt
schon zwei dreimal slattery hochgeladen
es gibt es auch auf dem handy
danke für die info deswegen lade ich das
heute das hier ist das menü ist übrigens
im hintergrund ist wieder mein altes
zimmer war ich bin meine eltern und ich
bin total verpennt wir geben als
nickname einfach mal ganz simpel luca
ein blick noch play online und sind dann
hier quasi der welt drin die steuerung
ist ein bisschen komisch und man muss
sich mit dem finger so hin und her
ziehen sodass der fährt und ich kann
teilweise einfach gar nicht sehen wir
dann hinterher immer hier ist wieder so
ein ding sunstein das weiß ich nämlich
auch nicht wie zum fix schneller es geht
auf jeden fall ich habe schon eine hallo
opa die alle riesig kommen tötet euch
mal bitte gegenseitig so dass ich
einfach nicht bei den essen kann
vielleicht es ist möglich dass man
kurzzeitig schneller fährt
ich weiß nur nicht wie also ich hab
versucht hier unten rechts das ist die
karte da sehe ich genau das feld ist
rund für diesen das für nen steher
rechts fährt beispielsweise gerade
schneller und jetzt wird er wieder
langsamer also es ist auf jeden fall
möglich ich weiß allerdings nicht wie
ich habe schon probiert mit zwei
verschiedenen händen oder steuerten nur
eine andere richtung wieder wenn nicht
doppelklick ich habe daraus geformt
es ist tatsächlich langweiliger als auf
dem pc
das muss man auf jeden fall festhalten
es geht nicht so schnell voran
man kann nicht so schnell in die
topliste kommen es ist langweilig
rio ist langweilig ich bin jetzt gerade
am rand der map angekommen wenn ich
dagegen fahren kann mir das vielleicht
bei einer sagen dass man steht wenn man
gegen den rand der map fertig machen
sollen da ist bei addario ist das doch
auch nicht so dass wir nicht den rand
der pfarrer das dann einfach tot bin war
hier schön lange wir da meine fresse
okay okay
die intelligenz des hamam hamm hamm hamm
hamm hamm haben mensch ist das lecker
ein paar sekunden später das was der
will mich das ist doch das ist nicht
erlaubt dass der will mich jetzt
wirklich hier drin behalten dass dass er
mich oder wie ja toll bist du [ __ ] ein
sohn
ich mag es nicht
ich mag es einfach nicht das ist halt
die scheiße man kann in dem spiel übels
schnell übels gut werden aber man kann
auch übel ist schnell übel schlecht
werden und bei mir ist es tatsächlich
öfter so dass ich über stelle wird
schlecht werde ich will einfach dass wir
noch mal genau das gleiche passiert wie
mir vorhin passiert ist dass das war
einfach krass ich hatte einen score von
2.500 innerhalb von einer minute jetzt
bin ich wieder schlecht wie scheiße was
will denn der amerika fitze lasst mich
doch eine hohe wird augen verpacken kann
denn wenn man wenigstens dann wieder ins
game rein kommen könnte oder so aber man
man das geht das ist ich verstehe es
nicht verstehen nicht wie man dahin gut
sein kann hier schwimmen wieder die
chance hat alles klar
dill dorfen kopf ich werd nicht mehr
viel war warum es ist auch einfacher
mensch werden hier jemanden mit diesen
doppelklick shit einzufangen als einfach
total die beschissene steuerung ist ich
mein wenn es wenigstens wie bei agatha
auf mandy gibt's ja unten links und
kleinen knopf wo man quasi sehen kann
okay wenn ich den knopf habe dann kann
ich damit steuern gott ist der lang da
vorne alter der oma nena okay ich habe
jemanden irgendwie aufgegessen glaube
ich es hört sich wahrscheinlich so als
würde ich jedes spiel irgendwie schlecht
preise aber es ist ja gar nicht der fall
ich mein spiel ist eine ultra coole
ideen und ich finde die steuerung hätte
man tatsächlich auf dem handy ein
bisschen besser machen können und warum
ich denn jetzt hier schon wieder so
lange lulatsch kann der roma okay er ist
einfach mal gestorben
das kann man sich ab
gerade gut mit sterben ja so ist das
wenn man ein schweres spiel und bist
mich kann tut mir leid stuhl
das wird nicht mehr vorkommen also ich
zog dieses spiel hier und immer wenn ich
gerade gut bin oder vor mir jemand
verrückt und ich den echten willen
kommen andere die vier finger gewandter
sind als ich und dessen dass auch ist
doch was anderes wie blöd map den hat
sich auch das dass das war das ist aber
schon das ist freundlich beendet an
dieser stelle das video ich kann das
game wirklich auf dem handy nicht auf
dem pc auch nicht wenn ich das hier
vielleicht trotzdem irgendwie
unterhalten konnte freue ich mich über
jeden einzelnen daumen hoch ich freue
mich wirklich über jeden alter immer
wenn einer kommt mache ich party
ich habe was ich hier das ist habe ich
von einem zuschauer zugeschickt ob ich
damit wohl die pflanze da hinten
wir sehen uns irgendwann wieder freunde
was ist denn wenn ich jetzt schießen
kommt oft raus